buonasera buonasera a tutti e tutti mi
hanno invitato qui questa sera perché
insieme ad un team di persone molto
molto visionarie abbiamo deciso di
portare il mare a milano
direte voi che questo è impossibile ma
davvero non l'avete mai visto la
spiaggia di porta venezia
la baia di gae aulenti la famosissima
scogliera del duomo
io le vedo ed è questo il mio talento
se pare che se sono qua almeno un
talento
io me lo devo riconoscere e credo che
fin da bambino il mio talento speciale
sia quello di sognare ad occhi aperti e
di riuscire a coinvolgere gli altri nei
miei sogni ma all'inizio io non ero così
consapevole di questo lato di me
certo io sentivo delle cose
vedevo delle cose bellissime ma allo
stesso tempo ero anche disorientato e
quando sei disorientato spesso cominci
ad errare e io ho cominciato ad errare
ero uno di quei tv a cui piace cambiare
spesso ho portato con me un po di foto a
6 anni ero un tennista prodigio a 8 anni
suonavo il pianoforte a 10 anni
naturalmente ero un calciatore provetto
a 14 anni ero vice campione di
canottaggio al fotofinish a 18 anni ero
matricola la bocconi ha 22 anni ero
matricola al dams ha 23 anni ero
matricola all'accademia nazionale d'arte
drammatica a 26 anni finalmente ero un
giovane attore a 30 anni ero ancora un
giovane attore ha 32 anni ero un giovane
danzatore
ora voi capirete che kimi era vicino gli
amici parenti
mi dicevano che ero in costante
discontinuo che non portavo a termine
quello che avevo cominciato io pensavo
no no che non sono discontinuo io non
sto interrompendo nulla io sto solo
cambiando
io stavo eraldo fin da bambino credevo
che bastasse credere che tutto è
possibile per rendere possibili cose
impossibili per gli altri per convincere
gli altri che i sogni possono diventare
realtà
e ancora oggi credo che il solo credere
che tutto è possibile
equivalga a sognare e sognare equivalga
ad errare il superman nella foto era
davvero io d'altra parte non sono più un
bambino
se continuo a credere che tutto è
possibile se continuo a credere che i
sogni possono cambiare il mondo
o sono diventato pazzo c'è qualcuno che
lo crede o sono diventato un
imprenditore sociale imprenditore
sociale è un modo adulto per dire
sognatore ad occhi aperti organizzato sì
sì la la la mia è la storia di un
sognatore errante che è diventato un
imprenditore sociale anzi meglio essere
imprenditore sociale il modo in cui il
mondo mi ha dato un posto nella società
proprio in quanto sognatore errante il
mio sogno da imprenditore sociale
si chiama mare culturale urbano quello
che vorrei trasmettergli questa sera
raccontandovi della nostra impresa di
portare il mare a milano beh che non c'è
conoscenza senza errare e senza errore
che senza errare non si costruisce il
cambiamento e mare è la prova che quelli
che per altri
alcuni erano i minatori in realtà erano
il mio errare solo il mio errare mi ha
portato a conoscenza di quale fosse il
mio sogno solo il mio errare mi ha
portato a incrociare tutte le mie reti e
trasformare questo incrocio nel mio
sogno ma la cosa più importante che io
ho imparato errando che da soli si
cambia certo ma non si cambia il mondo
ma io era il mondo che volevo cambiare
altrimenti che sognatore ero e allora ho
dovuto imparare a sognare insieme ad
altre persone
ho dovuto imparare a sognare un sogno
più grande
ciao
per cento
quella che avete visto in questo video è
la visione che stiamo facendo diventare
realtà realizzare questa visione è la
vita che sognavo da bambino quando
ancora non conoscevo quale fosse il mio
sogno ora lo so il mio sogno è costruire
luoghi fisici luoghi della mente e
luoghi dell'anima luoghi in cui le
persone possano stare insieme in nome
della bellezza e non in nome del consumo
il mio sogno è che la parola centro
possa evocare la parola culturale e non
la parola commerciale il nostro sogno è
quello che le persone possano
incontrarsi per davvero che chi fa
teatro danza musica possa farlo insieme
ad i cittadini e per i cittadini
il mio sogno il nostro sogno che chi
pensa che la parmigiana di melanzane sia
buona possa stare possa incontrare chi
pensa che la traviata sia bella sì
parmigiana di melanzane traviata sono
due concetti che insieme sono un'ottima
base per costruire un sogno
il nostro sogno è quello che le persone
incontrandosi possano conoscersi e
conoscere persone di ogni età di ogni
provenienza sociale di ogni provenienza
culturale unite dalla bellezza la
bellezza che è una pratica una pratica
di costruzione di condivisione e di
inclusione e quindi noi abbiamo
cominciato ad immaginare progettare e
costruire questi luoghi dai bambini e
dai ragazzi nei luoghi si stanno
formando uomini ragazzi fanno diventare
adulti perché non lavorare non centro
culturale urbano contemporaneo deve
essere un punto di riferimento per chi
lo attraversa uno spazio vivo che
accompagni la crescita di una comunità
di riferimento
uno spazio inclusivo e trasversale uno
spazio dove il diverso è ricchezza e
l'incontro tra diversi diventa un tesoro
è così che è il mio sogno ma poco si fa
sempre più tangibile il cambiamento non
più una cosa che mi accade per caso ma
un obiettivo consapevole da raggiungere
sono diventato un imprenditore sociale
culturale contemporaneo contemporaneo
contemporaneo contemporaneo definire
contemporaneo questo è difficile ma ci
provo non sociale non è contemporaneo
non è contemporaneo
accumulare e aumentare il proprio
privilegio a discapito degli altri non è
contemporaneo investire senza sognare
non è contemporaneo costruire la
sostenibilità di un progetto senza
errare e soprattutto non è contemporaneo
sbagliare da soli
almeno questo è il mio sogno di
contemporaneo
io credo che bisogna cercare di essere
radicali e ossessivi nel perseguire la
direzione del proprio sogno anche se è
una direzione ostinata e contraria a
quella usuale anche se gli altri ti
stanno dicendo star rando e proprio
lager today di rispondere io io sto
proprio andando io sto proprio errando
solo dalle rare e dall'errore si trae la
forza per spostare il mare si trae la
forza per rialzarsi quando si cade si
trae la forza di costruire questo è il
team di mare culturale urbana noi stiamo
imparando che ci vuole molta forza per
costruire il cambiamento e che non si
esce che se non si cambia
il sogno si spegne e che se non si ha
cura del proprio sogno nel sogno degli
altri e della propria vita e della vita
degli altri
il sogno si spegne e se il sogno si
spegne non si era più ma ci si ferma al
proprio piccolo interesse e al proprio
piccolo benessere parlando insieme
invece tutto cambia
non più la propria felicità il proprio
benessere e poi il vuoto ma un orizzonte
condiviso di un sogno comune noi e amare
diciamo costruire l'improvviso ci stiamo
accorgendo di come tutto si sgretola
attorno a noi
i poveri sono sempre di più e sono
sempre più poveri i ricchi sono sempre
gli stessi e sono sempre più ricchi io
credo io credo che bisogna cercare
ossessivamente le soluzioni per una
crescita comune
io credo che bisogna cercare
ossessivamente ricreare le condizioni
per cui a stare bene sia in tanti
il nostro sogno è quello di costruire
questa resistenza attraverso l'arte e la
cultura attraverso il teatro la danza la
musica che così non sono più vissute
come un oggetto di consumo ma come parte
integrante della vita la vita l'arte
l'arte e la vita l'arte è innesco vitale
per la trasformazione delle persone
l'arte che parte dalla vita che parte
dal dai problemi della società
contemporanea se interroga si discute
l'arte che parte dallo specifico per
creare linguaggi universali per fare
poesia produrre bellezza noi per fortuna
siamo sempre influenza bili dalla
bellezza che ci circonda quindi dobbiamo
essere con tutto noi stessi costruttori
di bellezza con tutto noi stessi
portatori sani di bellezza per
contagiare il mondo portare mare in una
città come milano significa prima di
tutto portare una nuova filosofia una
nuova proposta di vita sociale e
culturale
questa filosofia si si fonda sul sogno
si fonda sulle rare e si fonda sul fatto
che parlando insieme tutto può cambiare
guardate queste sono le immagini che i
cittadini milanesi ci hanno mandato in
risposta alla nostra sfida di sognare il
mare a milano ci hanno risposto in tanti
con le loro visioni tutti atlanti e con
il mare negli occhi e nel cuore
grazie